- [Kim] Hi, I'm Kim from Khan Academy,
and I'm here with Meaghan, who
leads U.S. Teacher Education.
Hi, Meaghan.
- [Meaghan] Hi, Kim.
In this video, we are
going to walk you through
the Khan Academy learner
or student experience.
- [Kim] So, Meaghan, who
is considered a learner
on Khan Academy?
- [Meaghan] At Khan Academy,
we believe that everyone
is a learner, and from
the teacher perspective,
all of your students are
learners and you can be as well.
- [Kim] That's great.
So where should teachers start
if they want to better
understand the student experience
on Khan Academy?
- [Meaghan] To begin, you wanna log into
your Khan Academy account.
Then select the navigation
button indicated by your name
on the top right of the screen.
Once you see the drop-down
menu, select Learner Home.
You can now see the Learner
homepage on your screen.
You can think of this as
the student's homepage,
as this is what students see immediately
when they log into Khan Academy.
Also, a quick tip: if
the student clicks on
the Khan Academy logo, no
matter what page they are on,
assuming they are logged
in, they will always be
taken back to this homepage.
On the left-hand side, any
classes the student is in
and where the teacher
has given them some sort
of assignment or goal is listed.
As you can see, the course
mastery goals and assignments
recommended by the teacher are accessible
with a single click.
Within the Assignments tab,
learners can easily see
upcoming assignments and work directly
on the assignments from there.
Within the Course Mastery
tab, learners can see
the mastery goals you have given them
and their progress towards it.
By going down to the Progress tab,
students can see their activity log.
This exact same report is also
available to you as a teacher
when you click into a
student on your roster.
We surface the report to both
facilitate accountability
and to stimulate student-teacher
conferencing on progress.
By scrolling down and
clicking on Teachers,
students can see all of
their current teachers
and also join a new class
by entering a class code.
One more thing: on this
page, students will also find
a summary of their recent activity,
energy point, and badges earned.
- [Kim] That seems like a
really useful place for students
to check current mastery
progress, assignments,
and overall learning.
Can you walk us through what
students experience when
they select their mastery goals?
- [Meaghan] Of course, Kim.
When students click on their mastery goal,
they are taken to the course page,
where they can work through
the course at their own pace.
What you see here on the course
page are the different units
that make up the course, as
well as the student's progress
towards mastering each unit.
Below each unit name are the
lessons within each unit.
By clicking into a lesson or unit,
I am taken to the unit page.
From here, students have
the option to either
dive straight into practice,
which they can find
on the right-hand side, or first check out
the learning material, which
are the articles and videos
on the left-hand side.
There are a couple types
of practice activities
in Khan Academy's mastery system.
Exercises, which are opportunities
for students to learn
single skills in
isolation, or assessments,
where students get mixed skill review.
The different types of assessments address
different quantities of content.
Quizzes are mixed review
of skills in a lesson,
unit tests are mixed review of
skills within an entire unit,
and course challenges are
a mixed review of skills
from the entire course.
- [Kim] And how does Khan Academy assess
students' proficiency in
the skills they're learning?
- [Meaghan] As students
work through the content,
Khan Academy assesses their skill level,
giving them a designation
of attempted, familiar,
proficient, or mastered.
These levels are surfaced in
the teacher progress reports,
but students can also quickly
understand their level
by looking at the tower
visual next to each skill.
One brick for familiar,
two for proficient,
and the crown is unlocked at mastered.
When students work on skills in isolation,
the maximum level they
can get to is proficient.
They would need to
answer all the questions
in isolated skill practice
correctly to get to that level.
The only way to get to
mastered is by proving
students can ace questions
related to that skill
in a mixed skill context,
so they need to complete
the assessments for that final level-up.
If students have tried the skill and get
70 to 99% correct, we call them familiar.
If they earn less than
70%, they are attempted.
- [Kim] I saw a banner
for mastery challenges
on the course page.
What are mastery challenges?
- [Meaghan] Great question, Kim.
Mastery challenges are a way for students
to review and practice
previously learned skills
in a course.
They first get unlocked after the student
has gotten to familiar
on at least three skills
and continue to get unlocked
every 12 hours afterwards.
They also provide another
way beyond unit tests
and course challenges for
students to level up or down
in already familiar skills.
Mastery challenges highlight
opportunities for students
to engage in personalized,
spaced repetition of the skills
students have already started practicing.
Research shows that
spiraling skills over time
and across lessons is a key component
to minimizing student learning loss
and improving knowledge retention.
- [Kim] You mentioned that students can
see assignments from teachers.
How do students know which
assignments to complete?
- [Meaghan] From the Learner homepage,
students can select assignments from
the left-hand panel under each class.
Students will see active
or current assignments
in the order of what is due
soon at the top of each list.
Each assignment will show
the title of the assignment,
the class name, the due date,
and the status of the assignment.
If the assignment is a video or article,
it will show as completed
or not completed.
If the assignment contains questions,
it will show the student's best score.
By clicking on the assignment
name or the status,
which will show as a Start
button for new assignments,
the student will be taken
directly to the assignment.
If students want to
revisit past assignments,
they can click the tab
for Past Assignments
on the top of the page.
- [Kim] This is so helpful,
Meaghan, thanks so much.
We hope this video provides
a better understanding
of the student experience on Khan Academy.